nearly 40 nearly 40 of small businesses
in the US fail to pay rent in October
this is a Daily Mail story
the findings published Tuesday by
boston-based business tracker alignable
illustrates the Stark effect inflation
is having on everyday Americans the
survey of 4789 small business owners
some more than half of respondents say
their rent is at least 10 percent higher
it was six months ago interesting ten
percent higher than it was six months
ago if you go back even seven months the
majority said rents have increased 20
percent this twenty twenty percent so if
you're paying 10 grand a month now it's
twelve thousand dollars a month the
study found that roughly 37 percent of
small business owners almost half of all
Americans working in private sector were
left unable to pay rent in October
compounding concerns is the fact that
several states such as New York and
California are already well over already
we're well over the already high
national average uh Tom what are your
thoughts when you see a number like this
how important is this to the average
person this is hugely important because
this is the dry cleaner down the street
that you go to this is the little
butcher shop in Brooklyn that you go to
this is the small businesses you go to
this is the the bead and Art Shop that
your daughter goes to and gets those
little things for crafts after school
these are small businesses sitting there
on Main Street America that are now this
is the plumber that you've used for 20
years and now his little his little shop
where he Parks his trucks and his guys
come in and he's got a few sinks on
display and stuff his rent is up what
this is saying is this is real and so
these these folks are going what are
they gonna have to do they're going to
have to raise prices a little bit on you
that's inflation to the average person
you say wow this is terrible no this is
the front end of inflation the rent goes
up so they have to raise the price that
you pay it's the front end of inflation
and this is to me the the real fire in
the mouth of the Dragon hasn't been seen
and we're going to see it right here as
we go into the end of the year Pat I
mean this is the fire in the mouth the
dragon is what I mean
I I just can't say it any any more clear
it's why is the dragon have so much
stuff in his mouth what do you mean like
the the fire in the mouth of the Dragon
well I mean things are getting hotter
you've got now people these are
businesses are about to close these are
people that have a risk of going out of
business this isn't just a little
increase in the unemployment rate this
is these are small businesses that's
that are building the jobs are the core
of the economy and I'm saying that the
dragon breathing fires inflation and
this is a leading indicator got it
that's the key that's the word I was
looking for for leading indicator check
this out can you pull up Airbnb
what happened with their quarterly
earnings just type in Airbnb quarterly
earnings okay
and their numbers I think just came out
two or three days ago go to news go to
news at the top
go to yeah there you go go to news zoom
in a little bit
zoom in a little bit so we can there you
go click on that right there boom click
on the first one CNBC
uh Airbnb earnings ninety percent
it's okay I don't want them 90 their
traffic is coming to the pro no go to
the top one that's the one I want yeah
so look at this shares of Airbnb tumble
13 on low fourth quarter guidance okay
go zoom in a little bit more so we can
read that uh for the fourth quarter
Airbnb set it expects to deliver between
1.8 billion to 1.88 billion below the
midpoint of 1.85 as expected by an
analyst go a little lower
so why this Airbnb data matter okay
Airbnb beat on timer the company posted
a revenue of 2.9 billion Tony every time
we get over here it's only 2.8 billion
but Airbnb provided fourth quarter
Revenue guidance at 1.8 1.85 everyone is
expected to a continued uh albeit choppy
recovery of cross-border travel to be
further Tailwind to Future results as
count countries around the world
continue to recover from covert
lockdowns and grapple with high-level
inflation rates Airbnb also cautioned
that the strong dollar will lower its
International average daily rate
analysts at evercore isi said that this
was the key negative in the opponents of
games all in we have fundamental Trend
we're resilient okay so if people are if
airbnb's numbers are 13 lower to Tumble
their stock tumbles because they're
thinking traffic's not going to be as
high why are people not traveling as
much why are people not spending that
money that's another indicator you have
to be careful with that people are not
spending that money there are certain
areas exotic cars down collectible cards
down nfts down nearly 94
you can go through so many of these
things that people just kind of throwing
money at it yeah you want to go on a
vacation let's go get an Airbnb yeah you
want to go let's go buy a collectible
card the same Kobe Bryant card that's
one of two that sold for 1.7 million
dollars
two years ago I want to say sold for 690
000 two months ago
okay there's only two of those cards
it's his best card in the world only
sold for six six ninety roughly 700 000
this card got a 1.7 million dollars a
year and a half ago in the last 12 18
months same exact card same you know how
we say VIN number same exact
identification everything's the same so
for more than 50 why
why are people not doing it I don't know
maybe people are hoping they keep their
cash because they're going to need it
for other places so when you're seeing
businesses not paying rent forty percent
of our behind that's problematic you
need those guys to be paying their rent
so if you like this clip and you want to
watch another one click right here and
if you want to watch the entire podcast
click right here
[Music]